Patrick my home super bowl 50 for MVP
spoke with Peter King not just after the
game he did that he's also spoken to him
more recently for a half hour the
conversation debuts Tuesday on the Peter
King podcast so Peter the dust has
settled the confetti has fallen Patrick
my Holmes had a chance to catch his
breath and and ponder what had been what
did you learn from mahomes when you
spoke to him well I talked to him Friday
morning for a half hour and I thought
what was a good sign after seeing him
you know catch a line drive Coors Light
and shotgun it and then spike it I said
man this been a fun week for you and he
was just on his way home from working
out but when he called me and so good
look at this I mean this is I don't know
that there you go that's a 24 year old
kid I love that and you're and we're
replaying it for replay but no I mean
this is one thing but I think the fact
that he's 24 years old he had fun and he
had his fun and he's gonna continue to
have it that's one thing but as his dad
told me he goes look Patrick's gonna get
back in the lab and he's gonna work hard
he's gonna come back better I mean that
is one thing that I know Patrick mahomes
and Andy Reid will be working on his
zits this offseason two things about the
game I found interesting number one
third and 15 late in the game and
obviously right before he throws his 44
yard completion to Tyreke Hill he told
me that hey regardless of what happened
on third down even though there was
seven and a half minutes to go at that
point they were going for it on fourth
down they were not gonna punt the ball
back to to San Francisco which I knew
was a little bit of I kind of thought
they would punt because they had their
timeouts but he said no the other thing
Mike just overall overriding interesting
to me about mahomes and his dad you know
it's very well known that mahomes his
father brought him into clubhouses
starting when he was four years
years old with the Mets in 1999 Pat
mahomes being an 11-year major-league
pitcher but the thing that really
interested me is that this continued
long after mahomes is Pat mahomes his
pitching career ended and it continued
all the way into independent leagues
when young Pat mahomes would spend part
of his summers on the buses in the
independent leagues in Sioux Falls South
Dakota and his dad wanted him to see a
what the work was like and be that it is
always all about the next pitch forget
what you've done it is about what you
will do and I thought that really came
in handy for mahomes midway through the
fourth quarter when as Troy Aikman said
on Fox he has not played well you know
he threw the ball too terrible
interceptions you know in a nine minute
span and then he had to come back and
and so to me that's the sign of a really
good football player when you could put
real crap behind you well and it really
is not easy to do one of the things I
love to do watching a game is study the
demeanor of the players and how many
times do we see guys who just have that
it's really not my day
vibe horndog I just I just want to go
home right can we just get this over
with I mean we have been at games like
that as fans where we just want to get
the hell out of there and we have the
ability to do so and we've seen players
from time to time and I don't want to
pick on anyone in particular but that's
been one of the knocks on Cam Newton
then when everything's going well it's
the big smile it's the Superman thing
and when things aren't going well he
looks like somebody who just wants to go
home he just accepts the fact it's not
my day and you rarely see him turning
around in the middle of a bad game and
it's not easy to do it's not just Cam
Newton there were very few quarterbacks
who can find the gas pedal after three
and a half quarters of just flailing
around for it and you have to forget
about everything that's happened if
you're gonna have any hope of turning it
on and I think it's a great lesson for
everyone but it's not an easy thing to
master and and I think that
one of the reasons Peter that even
though the Chiefs were down 24 - the
Texans 10 - the Titans twice and down 10
in the fourth quarter - the 49ers and
came back and won the Super Bowl there's
this sense there on the front end of a
dynasty because I think we just accept
the fact that if they can do this they
can do anything hey it's just like I
said to him the other day it kind of
reminds me of what Russell Wilson did in
the championship game a few years ago
against Green Bay throws four
interceptions he's the worst player on
the field and what happens you know he
has no acceptance whatsoever
of losing and know even acknowledgement
of losing and he's gonna come back and
do everything he can to try to win and
he wins an overtime you know with the
great throw to to curse to win the game
and and look I guess I just look at this
whole thing and I say just as Bill
Belichick was raised in a household with
a mother who was very well-read and and
a former teacher who would make him read
his homework to her when she was
preparing dinner and then the data was
the great football coach and scout at
the Naval Academy you see both those
sides of Bill Belichick and right now
what you see in Patrick mahomes is a
never-say-die guy who's been around it
his whole life who loves it
who just desperately wants to be great
and and and he's seen it now with Derek
Jeter with Alex Rodriguez with all these
guys in Major League Baseball I mean
heck a rod gave him it took batting
practice with him so in my opinion this
guy is in a golden position to have a
great career the thing you said that
should make the Chiefs fans feel the
best and scare the bejeebers out of
everyone else is that he's going to get
better that he's going to go into the
lab and emerge a better get ready rest
of the NFL a new and improved Pat
mahomes is coming
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports